hey guys welcome back to City skylines
this is one of my favorite episodes in
this series since I'll be working on a
theme park it's not going to be anything
big it's going to be a pretty small sort
of local theme park kind of idea
especially considering that at the time
when this was recorded which is quite a
while ago now there weren't too many
assets to make theme parks with and I
was kind of in doubt whether I should
really try it but I really just felt
like something that should be doable
pretty well in this game and just
something I've been wanting to try for
such a really long time that I really
wanted to give it a shot here and the
basic idea for the theme park is pretty
simple I think you can generally just
sort of divide theme parks into two main
categories they're only like really
large pre-planned
parks that are light laid out at once
like the Disney parks which are all very
much planned beforehand and all just
built in one go and then are the more
sort of family-run or growing over time
kind of theme parks that start out as
like smaller playgrounds or something
like that and only over time get more
attractions and develop into larger
theme parks and it's sort of in the lot
in like the latter category that I think
this one fits into it definitely has
doesn't have the sort of Disney layout I
didn't feel it would be really doable
with the things that we have it's much
more doable I think to just go for
something that's a little bit more
random a little bit smaller and on the
smaller scale as well less heavily
themed just go for something in which
you can kind of just blob the assets in
and create a fun little theme park and
starting off with the park I wanted to
have a Main Street which is more of a
Disney thing but this park was inspired
by a park in the Netherlands that you
might know if you're in touch it's
called la Jara it's not particularly big
theme park it's not very famous and it
definitely doesn't have the best
reputation but it's just they are pretty
small nice theme park that I figured I
could make something similar to it just
with different attractions and different
themes and the different layouts but a
similar sort of idea and size to it so I
wanted to start off with a main streets
over here much like Sahara which also
has a small Main Street
and the most doable theme since I didn't
want to I didn't want to make this a
theme park with the actual theme I think
it would actually be to go with the
Dutch theme which is not just kind of
fits the general Dutch theme of this
city honestly but it also felt like the
most doable thing here and also the most
well from from a realistic standpoint
this is in the Netherlands and having a
theme park that's themed after the
Netherlands itself would be a pretty
cool thing to have so just having a
standard sort of small Main Street which
can have like some restaurants and entry
sort of services in it with a ferris
wheel at the end which isn't too big but
does make like a really nice entry into
the park with like something big at the
end of the streets and on both sides of
the Main Street I sort of divided the
park into two different parts and try to
like have one sort of central area with
both of the both of these parts and sort
of divide the attractions equally
throughout these points so I wanted to
get this right side in with just a
couple of buildings and a bier Garten
just to be able to get a restaurant in
and make that Plaza in front of it using
the concrete textures
I'll cover up the profits later I had to
have some functional roads and I just
went for the gravel roads in the end but
you're not going to end up seeing those
I just needed to have the functional
roads to actually be able to place
assets alongside it of course and they
do kind of generally mark off the
general layout of the paths in the park
but yeah so basically this area is just
going to have that sort of central plaza
with the Biergarten
and the drop tower and down here I just
wanted to have like one of these more
like very quiet rest areas in the park
with some toilets and picnic tables and
just a general place where you can just
kind of relax in the park and not have
any thrilling experiences or anything
like that
and since coasters are often tucked in
the corners and the side of the size of
the theme parks I wanted to have one of
the wooden roller coasters in that site
there I think no that's a killer the
only wooden
Costa we had at this point in time I
think which I do have to say some of the
roller coasters are just definitely far
from realistic and don't actually have
any kind of lift or anything like that
that makes sense I am just trying to
sort of get the general look of the
theme park but not get it 100% because
definitely when it comes to the
attractions mostly the roller coasters
there's no way to get it exactly
realistic now moving on I also wanted to
have a bit of a like fancy area over
here and place a cinema over there which
if you haven't played well across I kun
in the original roller coaster kun and
roller coaster into there was a 3d
cinema which looked like this so there's
a lot of nostalgia involved probably and
me placing that but I really figured it
would be a nice way to get something in
that corner of the park and since it was
on the Steam Workshop I really figured I
can not place that in the park since
it's just well such a big well classic
within the theme park games and for
realism purposes I did want to make the
plots in which this theme park is
located like just the square within all
the farm fields that I'll have so it
also will fit within the grid of the way
that the farm fields are divided and I
basically didn't want to have a sort of
scattered around plots shape or a very
round looking Park since that just
wouldn't make sense and this also left
some room at the end especially the
edges of the park here to leave some
space open for services for staff or
maintenance or storage things like that
so I didn't want to keep this open in
place a couple of those buildings on the
side here just be able to have some sort
of backstage areas areas that the guests
can actually go to but they're mostly
just meant for staff and doing all sorts
of things which a theme park needs but
you don't actually want to see as a
guest and in the other corner and that
that right there is the corner next to
the highway so I figured that's where we
well basically want to have the biggest
roller coaster because we kind of want
to show off the park over there so I
place the biggest roller coaster right
over there near the dog-bone interchange
that's basically this parks
dick-measuring contest right there and
have a little path around it's just to
mark of what the edge of the park is
there is still room for one more coaster
I figured which upper and the other edge
on the other side but aside from that I
also didn't want to clog it up too much
and leave some areas open while at the
same time not making the park too big
since this is more of a like local small
theme park so I figured a nice way to
fill in the area over here is to add a
little pond like area next to the
greenhouse which isn't entirely a theme
park kind of attraction I should say I
was hoping to get something else in
there but at the time there weren't any
other theme park rides I know there's
definitely more now which are quite a
bit better as well but at the time this
was more or less everything and I also
didn't want to leave it empty which is
why I figured it would be nice to have
the greenhouse there and put a little
garden in front of it and there in the
edge I wanted to have the final roller
coaster since it is a pretty small
roller coast and it fits pretty neatly
in there and there's still even a bit of
space left for a nice little playground
in the future so I'll be filling that up
a bit as well and I also did want to
scatter a few restaurants and picnic
places in around here as well so this is
supposedly a small restaurant where
people can just sit over here and watch
the coaster stuff like that I figured
for a park this size it would make sense
to have just about two main restaurants
aside from the small stalls and little
shops that are just pretty much blocked
throughout the park I just have two main
large restaurants that people can eat at
which seems pretty reasonable for the a
park of their size and yeah that's
basically the sort of approach to these
services in this park now here I finally
cover up the paths which is pretty
similar to real life theme parks real
life theme parks do have very boring
parts in terms of their textures it's
mostly just concrete big slabs of
concrete just about everywhere but there
are sometimes interesting patterns
and some general ways that the parts are
laid out and over here I figured I more
or less had to do it this way since I
well didn't have any part texture of the
concrete texture that you can actually
lay over roads and at the time I also
didn't have any concrete roads because I
still need to use the first traffic plus
plus in order to actually run this park
since I started it started the park or
the city with it but yeah traffic plus
plus doesn't really work well anymore
some kind of stuck with that and I can't
use any concrete roads so this more or
less in like the next best thing and
since it did end up becoming quite a big
concrete desert over here and it I did
want to make it look a little bit more
charming than that so I figured a good
way to get more foliage into the park
what would be just to put some extra
planters here in there and put some
trees in that and basically make sure
that there aren't any sort of really big
vast concrete areas without making sure
that there are just a few trees here and
there as well and the biggest backstage
area is over here so I figured this
would be the most important place for
storage and maintenance and things like
that right there which also has a pretty
good connection to the rest of the park
without being too obvious of a
connection or too accessible for well
the regular guests really so that just
felt like a good way to fill in the
plots so that just I'm pretty happy with
how that turned out it also doesn't look
too square like I wanted to place the
park within that very square plots a
shape but I didn't want the park itself
to be too much boarded by that and be
all around the edges everywhere so I
don't think you notice the outsides of
the park too much when you're within the
park itself because you do try it you do
kind of try to hide the outside when
you're in the park itself and just have
a few very simple garden elements around
this part since it is pretty open and
empty I didn't want to make it a forest
especially since there is this nice
symmetrical path thing that the
greenhouse is going at the moment so I
didn't want to turn this into a very low
sort of park where you could still be
able to see the greenhouse from the
other side which also means that you
kind of have to mainly knees to main
things that sort of draw attention on
both sides of the park having the
greenhouse and having the drop tower on
the other side and of course having the
ferris wheel at the end of the Main
Street which is also really visible sort
of icon for the park so yeah that was
just a pretty simple garden right there
and just for realism purposes I also
wanted to of course dress it up a bit
with path elements so adding some extra
planters and some benches around the
area just to make sure that people can
sit around everywhere and just also to
make sure that the paths aren't that
empty because it's Billy easy for these
very big slabs of concrete everywhere to
just become this empty boring desert of
paths and that's something I really
wanted to try and avoid in this case
even though you barely actually notice
me placing all the benches and things
like that in the time-lapse I also
wanted to play some lanterns obviously
just to set the mood a bit but also to
light up the park and that is basically
the theme park itself now on the other
side and this is very much just ripped
off from La Jolla there was a pretty
common thing it's also very much like
the parking lots in front of Fantasyland
in Germany I wanted to have the parking
lots across this regional road over here
which already does get a lot of traffic
which is kind of awkward but it's just
about dealing with it well enough that I
figured this was safe to do have a small
bridge over the road just for
pedestrians so you don't get trouble
with that because it is a pretty busy
road and basically the parking lot
itself is very simple obviously I wanted
to have the bus stops very close to the
entrance so that's why there's this more
while the smaller concrete slab
alongside the road then I also wanted to
have the bus parking lots next to that
and only after that's actually have the
parking lots for cars which might seem a
little bit small I've gotten some
comments that this might be a bit of a
small parking lots but I kind of
compared it with the parking lots of
similarly skilled parks in the
Netherlands and it feels pretty safe to
go for this size
darn that's many people that only use
cars because public transport is pretty
decent though you'll probably never hear
Dutchman actually say that in the
Netherlands but yeah it's pretty decent
and very commonly used so I felt pretty
safe just going with a parking lot like
this which is not that big and just
dress it up a little bit though it still
has a parking lot so I didn't want to
make it too fancy and make it too nice
because that just well wouldn't really
fit with the idea of it being a parking
lot obviously and just to make it fit in
the general area though I haven't
completely filmed all of this since it
is much of the same of the last couple
of episodes I also wanted to dress up
the area around the theme park and make
sure that all the polos around it look
kind of realistic and that the grid
which the theme park plot has is also
kind of continued in the farm plots
because you do kind of want it to look
as if like over the years that the theme
park developed it it just bought plots
from farmers around it so the overall
shape of the park kind of does conform
to the shapes of the farm plots around
it and he'll it might actually be able
to expand in some point in the future
like buy some more plots around it be
able to actually make the park a bit bit
a bit bigger especially behind the
ferris wheel but that's just kind of
stuff I wanted to think about and just
leave in there but I definitely won't
expand the park myself just a bit more
backstage stuff on the other side and a
parking lots for the staff as well just
so they don't have to go to the busy
visitor parking lots and some trees run
here obviously to make the park not
stand out as much and since the since
the well the space between the highway
and the park can really be used for
anything I didn't want to fill those
spaces with just quite a few trees not
leave them just empty it also kind of
gives the think like a bit of a mystery
feeling around it since it is like the
entire park is surrounded by foliage be
it trees or bushes or hedges on all
sides and you can't really see
from the outside and you don't really
see the outside world from the
theme-park either but you do notice like
the drop tower and the really tall
coaster that's next to the highway when
you're on the highway or when you're on
the regional road which does sort of
draw you into the park and skipping
forward in the time-lapse this is what
it more or less ended up looking like
I'm pretty happy with how it turned out
and how it fits in the environment as
well and definitely one of my favorites
and most fun things to do as well of the
city in general so yeah that's it for
this episode a couple of things I do
want to say about the future I don't
think I'll continue much with the city
but my plan still is to make one last
episode in this series to make sure that
this city is round is basically just
finished
I might not turn it into episode and
just do a live stream of it still kind
of need to announce that a bit but I do
intend to still get around to at least
now not completely finish this but make
it presentable and after that I will
definitely make one final cinematic
video to show off what the city looks
like anyway that's it for this video so
thank you guys for watching and I hope
to see you guys I do in the next video
or in the final one